[Music]
washed out days
like the week before
Stone Cold Case
[Music]
don't
fail me now
don't be afraid
[Music]
down down into the deepest
my name
on the bedroom door
won't play the game
what you coming for
[Music]
fill me now
don't be afraid
[Music]
me
with me
[Music]
foreign
thank you
wasn't that sculpture cool they just
opened up that Park it's down in
Southwest on the waterfront right close
to the wharf and uh there's a bunch of
cool little stuff that just opened up in
there so um I'm gonna go exploring it
more and you might see more stuff from
that Park and others popping up in flow
videos in months in the future so keep
your eyes peeled in the meantime I just
want to give a quick shout out to ultra
POI for sponsoring this video and giving
me a reason to go out and explore DC's
many public art pieces you can grab a
set of those orb POI Pro LED contact boy
that I was using in this video by using
the promo code Drex factor of the zero
instead of an O over at ultrapoi.com
that gets you a discount on your order
and it helps out the channel so
everybody wins thanks once again to
ultra POI for sponsoring this video and
speaking of thank yous I also have a big
thank you to offer to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel That
is uh Lei machinsky and Becca Beck
London thank you both so very much for
supporting my work my channel and my
mission
and finally this video would not be
possible or not for the kind support of
all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people listed down
in the description helped to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently a
supporter but you'd like to become one
here's how you can do that head on over
to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to see some of
my other flow videos I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here so maybe give that a look as
well thank you so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today yourself
and I'll see you with a new video on
Friday
peace